as those who have known him best have
attested he has been an exemplary public
servant judge teacher coach husband and
father
mr. president I will vote to confirm
judge Cavanaugh that was Senator Susan
Collins delivering a crushing blow to
Democrats hoping for a last-minute
defection during her nearly one hour
long speech earlier today she echoed
many of the sentiments offered on the
Senate floor
day after day by our next guest we're
happy to be joined exclusively tonight
by Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell Senator McConnell when did you
know you had the votes when the roll was
called no they were all very guarded
about about making an announcement so
this is one of those rare situations
when you go into a vote not really
knowing for sure you had because you
would usually call cloture you don't
usually call cloture unless you know you
have the ultimate we had to move on this
this was not going to get any better if
we didn't vote I decided a week ago we
were gonna vote on Friday because we
watched what was happening they were
trying to destroy this good man with all
these rumors and all the rest of the
stuff so we needed to have the vote in
order to bring it to a conclusion
why didn't senator Mackowski ultimately
go along we got flake and you got
Collins of that long speech say she I
mean she really impressed a lot of
people with her passion and her
dedication to advise and consent what
happened to Murkowski well you know I'd
rather celebrate the victory and I think
there's plenty of credit to go around
president Trump for making great choices
chairman Grassley for doing a heck of a
good job in committee dealing with all
these outbursts my members dealing with
we've been under assault Laura there our
homes have been
the condor are yours was today and this
mu but not just me everybody I mean
they've been after all of us we've sort
of been under assault and everybody
decided to stand up to the mob you know
do not do not be intimidated by these
people I'm just couldn't be prouder of
my members for refusing to roll over
under all of this intense pressure all
these lies this is a great day for
America that Senate is under siege the
protesters don't seem to be letting up
even late in the afternoon into the
evening tonight is this the new normal
and I want to play something this is
sent to Senator Manchin this was after
the Colin's speech today and after he
said he would vote for Brett Kavanaugh
let's watch a lot of my radio callers
today said is this the way it's gonna be
I mean is there gonna be any changes to
building access you don't want to become
cocoon but any changes to to how you let
people into the building well I think
security will take care of that look I
think the main point is the mob was not
able to intimidate the Senate we stood
up to the mob we did the right thing for
a good man and fill the lifetime
appointment on the Supreme Court there's
a lot to celebrate today I couldn't be
prouder of all of my members senator
Collins it was outstanding you had part
of her speech in the in the entry but
the Democrats now have raised just
during her speech they raised almost two
million dollars on a GoFundMe page for
an undetermined candidate and Susan
Collins is apparently seriously
entertaining Susan Rice excuse me
entertaining a challenge against Senator
Collins in 2020 your thoughts Senator
Collins will be well funded I can assure
you that look there's a lot of
enthusiasm on our side too you may or
may not have notice that rising
enthusiasm among Republican voters I
think our people are going to be just as
fired up as there's a month from now and
everybody's gonna remember what they did
the press Cavanaugh is this the shot in
the arm that the Republicans needle
absolutely it is a it's a it's a wake-up
call to why it's important to hold the
Senate you know the Senate's on the
personnel business I love the house but
the Senate's and the personnel business
if you want to get judges confirmed
cabinet members confirmed boards and
commissions confirmed we have to control
the Senate so the president's
nominations can actually be confirmed
and take the jobs do you intend to use
this issue on the campaign trail for the
last four weeks and what are you going
to say about it
absolutely I'm gonna remind everybody of
the importance of the Senate to Supreme
Court appointments 26th Circuit Judges a
record for the first two years these are
lifetime appointments with conservative
men and women who believe that the job
the judge is to interpret the law as
it's written well what what about
repercussions for what happened during
this process I have I was here for Judge
Bork I was young speechwriter in the
Reagan administration I was here for
Justice Thomas obviously but I think
this actually rivaled both of those it
was brutal
and Lindsey Graham was on with us last
night and he talked about the need for
repercussions against the wrongdoers in
this case let's watch I believe Dianne
Feinstein didn't leak it but I don't
know about her staff I do know this her
staff recommended to dr. Ford miss Katz
who hates Trump is a politically active
leftist lawyer but why not get the
emails and text here's what I'm gonna do
anybody who did this is gonna pay a
price will they pay a price I think
it'll be investigated but you know it
didn't work I think the most important
thing to note here is these tactics did
not you don't want to go through this
again you want to is we're prepared to
go through it again they're not gonna
Intel they're not gonna tell us how to
vote and they've actually you know they
actually helped us win this vote their
tactics actually helped us unify our
people and win this vote they're gonna
help us win a month from now it on
November 6 - do you think you'll pick up
Senate seats and I hope so this this
underscores how important it is I mean
we have a close margin
very close margin I'd like to have a few
extra Republican senators let's talk
about the media's role in all of this
amplifying charges we had another point
I want to play from Susan Collins when
she talked about the rape rooms and that
these words that were being thrown
around against this it's steam judge
let's watch the allegation that when he
was the teenager judge Cavanaugh drugged
multiple girls and used their weakened
state to facilitate gang rape this
outlandish allegation was put forth
without any credible supporting evidence
and simply parroted public statements of
others including the media a celebrity
corn lawyer I mean I can remember when
that sort of thing was not put on the
air
I mean people didn't just peddle
nonsense with no corroboration that
really exacerbated the problem and a lot
of the Senate Democrats of course would
mainstream that stuff right into their
discussions and try to convince
everybody that it somehow happened no
corroboration at all just rumors all
over the place
senator Merkley from Oregon was quite
upset today he said this chuck Grassley
the chair of the committee and Mitch
McConnell the majority leader
[Music]
they said there's no contemporaneous
evidence to support the women who came
forward that is not true
well what are we missing here senator I
don't know what he's talking about there
was no evidence to corroborate any of
the allegations against judge Cavanaugh
maybe it's on a different planet I'm not
sure right now when you look back on
this last you know a couple of weeks and
you've had an incredible run of
confirming circuit court judges and
district court judges but just this
experience lessons learned for the
Republican Party the Senate maybe the
president going forward well I think
we've reaffirmed that in this country
you're presumed innocent the presumption
is in favor of innocence
we also relearn that you can't you
should not allow mobs to intimidate you
and I think the good lesson for us I
think it unified our conference made us
excited about the November election it
was good for the American people to see
that these people were stood up too and
they didn't get away with it they did
not win that's the most important thing
how radical has a Democratic Party of
today become it's from pretty well bunch
I mean it's pretty clear they were
willing to do anything say anything to
try to win there's no boundaries you
still have close friends in the
Democratic caucus after all this or
motions pretty raw I think we'll get
past it in terms of relationships but it
was a tough period a tough period
I hope they learned a lesson you can you
can do this kind of thing but it doesn't
necessarily get you to victory Mitch
McConnell congratulations thank you
thanks so much for being here